[Musique]
nous avons été saisis par un texte qui
venait de l'assemblée sur le harcèlement
scolaire le député qui portait ce texte
souhaité créer un délit spécifique et
nous nous pensons et nous avons beaucoup
travaillé que le droit existant permet
de sanctionner leur harcèlement donc
nous avons proposé la commission des
lois de créer une circonstance
aggravante dans le cadre du droit
existant qui permettait qui permet de
sanctionner effectivement leur seulement
scolaire dans sa spécificité mais pas
modifier le droit existant voilà pense
que nous avons des textes nous avons des
lois qui permettent aujourd'hui de
sanctionner un certain nombre de choses
c'est probablement intéressant et
nécessaire d'avoir ce critère spécifique
de l'année scolaire mais dans le droit
existant nous avons décidé et c'est très
important de restreindre le champ aux
élèves alors que le texte venue de
l'assemblée nationale précisait que les
adultes enseignants
assistants d'éducation éventuellement un
principaux de collèges pouvaient être
concernés par la notion de harcèlement
scolaire ce qui ne veut pas dire que les
adultes éventuellement coupable de
harcèlement envers leurs élèves ne
puissent pas être poursuivis ils le
peuvent d'ailleurs aujourd'hui la loi le
permet via un texte qui conscience qu'on
appelle le harcèlement moral le risque
d'inclure les adultes dans le texte et
dans le délit de harcèlement scolaire
c'est effectivement de donner une
possibilité pour certains parents qui
aujourd'hui conteste l'autorité des
professeurs
de pouvoir éventuellement effectivement
attaqué des enseignants sans réelle
justification la seconde chose c'est que
nous avons mis en évidence le fait que
la première éthique du harcèlement ce
concerne les harceleurs et harcelés mais
aussi les témoins les témoins qui
n'étaient pas pris en considération par
le texte venue de l'assemblée nationale
le mot témoins n'apparaissait pas enfin
il ya un dernier point qui est très
important nous avons changé déjà
l'intitulé du texte proposition de loi
visait à combattre le harcèlement l'air
désormais à la sortie du sénat elle vise
à combattre le harcèlement et le cyber
harcèlement parce que les outils
technologiques smartphones les réseaux
sociaux ont amplifié considérablement
malheureusement ce mal ce fléau
aujourd'hui c'est une hydre à mille
têtes qu'il faut couper pour combattre
le harcèlement scolaire et donc il nous
apparaissait essentiel de mettre en
évidence la notion de cyber harcèlement
et d'offrir les outils permettant de
mieux lutter contre